thank you
[Music]
critically acclaimed cellist Yo-Yo Ma
has played on the world's biggest stages
you're under presidential medal of
freedom and is a Kennedy Center honoree
now he's on a musical journey across the
country to bring people together through
nature and Psalm Mark straussen joined
ma in Great Smoky Mountains National
Park
now this was Virgin Territory in East
Tennessee
the miracle of the Great Smoky Mountains
National Park
meeting the Mastery of cellist Yo-Yo Ma
Yo-Yo Ma is the world's most renowned
cellist and its most famous a prodigy at
age four he has globetrotted most of his
life as a virtuosome
[Music]
soloing with the greatest orchestras on
the grandest stages but you can have no
ear for classical music and still know
the name yo-yo Mao in the Smoky
Mountains he popped into view and became
the National Park's most photographed
attraction hey give me five
whoa you're strong you were like the
Pied Piper really people just following
you
when did it occur to you suddenly that
you're a
classic musician who's something of a
rock star no I don't think of it as
Rockstar and I I mean I'd like to be a
friendly face for people even you like
people I love people
I'm fascinated by people it's like you
know there's another human being who are
they what do they do what do they
thinking and I want to connect with them
somehow it puts my mind at ease we met
under a canopy of hemlocks and hickories
the 67 year old talked about his latest
project called our common nature
[Music]
the cross-country musical Journey
visiting national parks and other
outdoor spaces like New River Gorge in
West Virginia Kentucky's Mammoth Cave
and the Grand Canyon too his goal
connecting to the natural world around
us
at each stop ma uncases one of his
cellos often more than 300 years old for
a free pop-up concert
this is not my space
[Music]
this is our common space
I'll come in nature do you what is the
connection between music
and nature music tries
to
describe
a world that is infinite it's always
about something bigger than itself here
in the Smokies ma played with three
Cherokee musicians at clingman's Dome
the Park's highest peak sharing the
story of their ongoing mission to
restore the Mountain's name to its 1800s
Cherokee title kuohi
you clearly like being out here I I love
it falling in love with nature with
ourselves connects us to a greater whole
that sometimes is subsumed by attention
to I gotta get to this appointment on
time even you you can be in too much of
a hurry to get to the stage to perform
always I mean my life is not unlike your
life or anybody else's life it's it's
very segmented
but with some notable exceptions his 19
Grammys his presidential medal of
freedom and Kennedy Center Honor if
America gave medals for stepping outside
Comfort zones ma would win those too
venturing far beyond Carnegie Hall in a
lifelong search for completeness
in journalism you're trying to tell the
best truth that you can find I try to do
that in music to say this is as much
truth as I can find and I'm not saying
this is all of it but this is the best I
can do how is the truth in your
cello playing different today than it
was before you began this National Park
tour oh my gosh I think
I am more in touch with the core of who
I am I'm more able to show what is
inside you're a better cellist no I
think I'm a fuller human being a fuller
being creating a fuller Harmony in
nature The Great Outdoors now a
Performing Arts Center
for CBS mornings Marx Rossman in
Gatlinburg Tennessee
mm-hmm
[Music]
[Applause]